dude my leg hurts today and you're and
you're in a bad mood because of it
that's not why I'm in a bad mood my leg
hurts but also the merch get your life
get your merch at lifelinemirch.com yeah
it's very good merch so my leg hurts and
that's not cool you keep I don't know
after your leg hurting I want to know
why is that interesting to talk about so
here's the only thing that I've done
differently in my life
and this would make a lot of sense but
then I have a caveat of when my leg
hurts this could make a lot of sense I
did lime scooters two two days in a row
for hours that was
Saturday and Sunday it's gonna make you
mad at what I say and it is Wednesday
it's gonna make you mad what I said I
don't know what you're gonna say and I'm
pissed it and I'm I'm pissed I know
preemptively so tell them what I'm gonna
say he's gonna say yeah sometimes it
takes a while for things to start
happening and it's probably the sort of
thing yeah I'm pissed
it's actually especially true when
they're muscles that you really not ones
that have atrophy but have are like less
commonly used by you right you don't use
your leg muscles you don't walk anywhere
you don't get on a bike ever you don't
you don't do you don't run what foreign
during the workout you jump yeah to wear
like how what you're working out and
you're like okay now now I'm doing jumps
jumps is a good workout dude I jump I
believe you but I don't believe that you
do him
yeah you do the boxing yeah so I'm not
like just like oh yeah we're the way
like what if you say jumping whoa whoa
everything's so light everything's so
light
so strong bouncing all over I was there
right when you were screaming first an
eyewitness an eyewitness I bet you you
hurt yourself when you almost fell off
the scooter okay well so oh now we're
airing it now the truth comes out we
have a witness and you got screwed over
for that let's just I didn't fall off
the scooter okay it sounds like you
almost first of all David fell off the
scooter and rolled and tumbled on the
grass and we went like like doing that
it was so funny we have it on video how
did you not dude I'm so
pissed at you what you're saying how
could you not tell me that I'm telling
you right now but how could you wait
this long to tell me it's like your leg
it's like it takes four days for your
leg to start hurting how could you wait
four days to tell me that you have on
video our friend David Sullivan who has
the largest skull bone yeah in the world
did the earth crack when his head hit
the ground no but I will tell you what
wow it's gonna it's it's well I didn't
get it with my phone we got it with the
actual camera so it's gonna be on the
Vlog oh so I'll send you the Vlog when
it comes out it'll be the Cincinnati
Columbus blog why whatever it was but oh
wow but dude it is the tour report but
dude he fell and and I mean oh my God it
was so [__] funny
got it oh he got it wow and I watched it
happen it was right next to me he rolled
past
foreign
like hurt a little too much but he he
was rolling and couldn't stop and and
was smiling as he was about to fall
because he knew he was [__] that's
great it was so good that's great but
that I still wish he was nervous
or like wanted to make it seem like it
was that was gonna happen or it wouldn't
hurt you yeah yeah yeah yeah perfect
that's always the best but no it was
great it was still funniest it's still a
high hilarity but so it'll be on the
Vlog but so make sure you sign up to my
crystal day Channel but um yeah yeah
yeah but uh so anyway so that's what
happened so I think that that might be
what my leg is but if not it might be uh
you know who knows maybe it's a [__]
huge why would your leg hurt because
David Sullivan fell what are you guys so
twins I wanted him to know that the
reason why I fell is because of
um no the reason why I have is David
Fell I did not fall I know that I get it
it almost fell and what you did I
wouldn't say I almost fell but did you
almost fall because David almost hit me
over no no no it's everything so why are
you denying it because I want people to
know that 10 miles an hour what you had
to do to stop yourself from falling is
you probably twisted your knee or
something like that yes how could you
leave that out me yeah I don't even
remember that happening but not leaving
it out you drove another one talking
think about how it happened and now I
remember it happened okay wow blocked it
out blacked it out but I don't know if
that's what it was couldn't bear to
think about it anyway there are four
days ago that that happened and now my
leg Yeah Dude yes because you don't use
your legs a lot that's why I do use my
legs a lot I do jumps I'm fit
hello hello
[Music]